boys can be girls girls can be boys men  can be women women becoming men  it makes me wonder  [Music]  what is a woman  what is a woman a woman is someone who  claims that as their identity  i'm a woman i claim female and woman as  my identity as you can see i am i'm a  man  i'm a fine ass man i'm a fine arts woman  apparently you know i mean humble  yourself  is it possible i can be a specific woman  so can i be rihanna  i bet you could i mean that can i be  posing  [ __ ]  who could i be  you could be  oh i could be will smith i'll leave  jaden  i'll do it for you i'll be jaded and try  to keep you okay where you going boy  but it's like these people are crazy i  don't under  and it's just crazy because i don't  think that we should be like  we shouldn't have to say this stuff no